Québec l'admet finalement :
oui, nous traversons
présentement une crise du
immobilière n'est pas sur
le point de ralentir.
Sébastien Desrosiers.
- Il en faudra plus pour
refroidir le marché immobili
Le prix des maisons bondit
plus rapidement que prévu.e pré.
DOMINIC ST-PIERRE, v-p
d'année, les prix commenceraient
à se stabiliser; puis
au contraire, les prix se sont
accélérés au premier trimestre.
Royal LePage, le prix
des propriétés a augmenté
de 18,5 % en un an
dans le Grand Montréal,
même 24,3 % sur la Rive-Nord,
alors que la hausse atteint
25 % à l'échelle canadienne.
Vanessa et son conjoint
découragés par la surenchère.
- Pour le moment, c'est pas
dans nos moyens parce que
c'est très élevé. Quand on voite
puis ils font des offres à
plus de 80 000 $ 9Rson,
on se dit : c'est hors de
c'est extrême, là.
- Ils sont victimes
d'un phénomène de rareté : trope
pour le nombre d'acheteurs.
- Habituellement, à ce moment-ci
de l'année, on devrait avoir
à vendre au Québec; puis
présentement, on est à moins
de 40 000, donc c'est ce qui cre
immense pression sur les prix.
MARTIN DESJARDINS,
courtier immobilierns sont asso.
Il y a des listes de gens
qui voudraient acheter
des propriétés cette semainey ae
d'inventaire.
- Difficile aussi de trouver
un logement à louer.
l'existence d'une crise
du logement.
ANDRÉE LAFOREST, min. Affaires
municipales et Habitation, Qc
que dans certaines régions,
certaines municipalités,
il y a une situation de crise du
logement. Maintenant, ça change
sur l'offre; c'est ce qu'on fait
depuis le début évidemment.idem.
On augmente l'offre de logements
au Québec.
plus de logements et de maisons
à vendre, mais les mises
en chantier continuent plutôt
de chuter.
Le prix médian d'une propriété
est présentement d'environ
571 000 $ mais si les prévis
de Royal LePage s'avèrent
exactes, il frôlerait
les 600 000 $ d'ic
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-C